And here's the pickle:
"And because you belong to them, I returned my hands and left you."
(Laughter)
Translate that for me.
(Applause)
So, what have we done to protect the Arabic language?
We turned this into a concern of the civil society,
and we launched a campaign to preserve the Arabic language.
Even though many people told me, "Why do you bother?
Forget about this headache and go have fun."
No problem!
The campaign to preserve Arabic launched a slogan that says,
"I talk to you from the East, but you reply from the West."
We didn't say, "No! We do not accept this or that."
We didn't adopt this style because that way, we wouldn't be understood.
And when someone talks to me that way, I hate the Arabic language.
We say--
(Applause)
We want to change our reality,
and be convinced in a way that reflects our dreams, aspirations and day-to-day life.
In a way that dresses like us and thinks like we do.
So, "I talk to you from the East, but you reply from the West"
has hit the spot.
Something very easy, yet creative and persuasive.
After that, we launched another campaign
with scenes of letters on the ground.
You've seen an example of it outside,
a scene of a letter surrounded by black and yellow tape
with "Don't kill your language!" written on it.
Why? Seriously, don't kill your language.
We really shouldn't kill our language.
If we were to kill the language, we'd have to find an identity.
We'd have to find an existence.
We'd go back to the beginning.
This is beyond just missing our chance of being modern and civilized.
After that we released photos of guys and girls wearing the Arabic letter.
Photos of "cool" guys and girls.
We are very cool!
And to whoever might say, "Ha! You used an English word!"
I say, "No! I adopt the word 'cool.'"
Let them object however they want, but give me a word that's nicer
and matches the reality better.
I will keep on saying "Internet"
I wouldn't say: "I'm going to the world wide web"
(Laughs)
Because it doesn't fit! We shouldn't kid ourselves.
But to reach this point, we all have to be convinced
that we shouldn't allow anyone who is bigger
or thinks they have any authority over us when it comes to language,
to control us or make us think and feel what they want.
Creativity is the idea.
So, if we can't reach space or build a rocket and so on,
we can be creative.
At this moment, every one of you is a creative project.
Creativity in your mother tongue is the path.
Let's start from this moment.
Let's write a novel or produce a short film.
A single novel could make us global again.
It could bring the Arabic language back to being number one.
So, it's not true that there's no solution; there is a solution!
But we have to know that, and be convinced that a solution exists,
that we have a duty to be part of that solution.
In conclusion, what can you do today?
Now, tweets, who's tweeting?
Please, I beg of you, even though my time has finished,
either Arabic, English, French or Chinese.
But don't write Arabic with Latin characters mixed with numbers!
(Applause)
It's a disaster! That's not a language.
You'd be entering a virtual world with a virtual language.
It's not easy to come back from such a place and rise.
That's the first thing we can do.
Second, there are many other things that we can do.
We're not here today to convince each other.
We're here to bring attention to the necessity of preserving this language.
Now I will tell you a secret.
A baby first identifies its father
through language.
When my daughter is born, I'll tell her, "This is your father, honey (Arabic)."
I wouldn't say, "This is your dad, honey (English)."
And in the supermarket, I promise my daughter Noor,
that if she says to me, "Thanks (Arabic),"
I won't say, "Dis, 'Merci, Maman,'" and hope no one has heard her.
(Applause)
Let's get rid of this cultural cringe.